[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión no lleva al sureste de francia
específicamente atom una comuna que el
2020 sufrió los embates de la naturaleza
durante la noche del 2 al 3 de octubre
de ese año la tormenta álex descrita por
los científicos como una bomba
meteorológica golpeó los territorios que
rodeaban la ciudad de niza en pocas
horas las lluvias torrenciales
provocaron graves inundaciones varios
ríos se desbordaron obligando a declarar
la alerta roja en el departamento de los
alpes marítimos de manera inmediata se
organizaron operaciones de evacuación
pero para algunos residentes atrapados
ya era demasiado tarde el número de
víctimas es considerable en los valles
de los altos marítimos 10 personas
perdieron la vida otras ocho
desaparecieron cientos de edificios y
carreteras quedaron completamente
destruidos a primera hora de la mañana
dentro de los sobrevivientes sólo pueden
ver los daños durante varias semanas los
más de dos mil habitantes vivieron
aislados del mundo sin agua ni
electricidad abasteciéndose de alimentos
y productos de primera necesidad que
llegaban por helicóptero o por
ferrocarril
los años materiales se estimaron en más
de 1000 millones de euros pero la
tormenta dejó a su paso heridas más
profundas y menos visibles más de 300
habitantes han dejado el municipio pero
otros aseguran que no dejarán el lugar
que los vio nacer
[Música]
el
éxito es
competitivo y víctima del sistema
intuitivo
me remito se limitó son con equis y eso
es falta de voluntad
el
estado
[Aplausos]
conservando
esta mañana en las alturas de té el tono
es solemne
los representantes electos y residentes
locales vinieron de todo el valle para
presentar sus respetos al niño local que
fue arrastrado por la tormenta hace un
año pero mayo este es un muy bonito
homenaje a mi pobre hermano un muy
bonito homenaje como como se siente hoy
está bien
lo estamos haciendo ir es difícil
la noche de la tormenta armand y su
hermanos llevaban a sus ovejas al redil
sintiendo que la tormenta los alcanzaba
a armand se puso al frente su hermano
iba a la cabeza
y
cruzamos ese puente y volvió a decirle a
mi hermano estamos salvados el puente
aguantó de repente oí que todo se
resquebrajaba
y que todo se iba a él las ovejas no hay
nada más que decir
arman también es arrastrado por las
aguas había ramas maderas y piedras que
golpeaban mis piernas y costillas
durante varias horas a pesar de la
violencia de la corriente resistió
colgado de un árbol
él es mi salvador él es el que aguanto
si no no estaría aquí
un año después el cuerpo de su hermano
aún no ha sido encontrado
no puedes hacer el duelo hasta que lo
encuentres no sé dónde está está allí o
en el mar no lo sé puede estar enterrado
debajo con 4 o 5 metros de tierra encima
y estos bloques de piedra que quieres
encontrar ya no podemos encontrar nada
hace unos días armand colocó una lápida
en el lugar donde desapareció su hermano
no está en el cementerio de todos modos
tendremos aquí cuando podamos
por lo menos cuando pasó por allí la veo
todos los días
yo pienso en él y me despierta
comediantes no dormía mucho ahora menos
que quiere que haga
[Música]
y eso es algo que guardaremos mientras
vivamos
aquí tienen dónde estamos search vivo
aquí en un pequeño estudio de 20 metros
cuadrados la gobernación se ocupa de mí
tras la catástrofe se fue realojado aquí
su casa está situada en una zona ahora
clasificada como peligrosa la cocina el
dormitorio el salón todo está ahí hasta
ahora ha estado pagando el alquiler
gracias a las ayudas del departamento
pero a partir del próximo mes tendrá que
asumirlo el mismo
si se acaban las ayudas estoy en la
calle y da mucho miedo
y pienso en ello todo el tiempo todos
los días vivo el día a día
no sé qué nos deparará el futuro
espero que me ayuden y sobre todo que
pueda encontrar un nuevo hogar como
ser yo vivía en la casa de su familia
junto al río a las afueras del pueblo
vivía de su pequeña pensión y del fruto
de su huerto
el carro casa no está mi tractor no está
mi garaje no está
la tormenta solo le dejó una maleta de
recuerdos y noches de insomnio
casi todas las noches sueño que estoy en
casas que hay una catastro que hay agua
tengo que salir
en realidad lo que viene después es el
choque
en este momento estamos tan sacudidos
que no entendemos lo que nos está
pasando
[Música]
un año después empiezo a darme cuenta de
los daños crítica
la tormenta tuvo un efecto duradero en
el valle y sus habitantes en su terreno
que ahora forma parte del nuevo cauce
solo el edificio es testigo de su
antigua vida
a pesar de un decreto de la prefectura
que le prohíbe la entrada 6 vuelve aquí
regularmente
los gatos y
no los gatos se quedaron no se movieron
se quedaron en casa un gato está ante
todo apegado solar el amo está en
segundo lugar pero sobre todo la casa no
se quiere vivir
y a ti te hace sentir bien volver aquí o
no
i
siempre filmar y hamilton
me duele pero al mismo tiempo necesito
venir
no puedo quedarme sin venir más vicky
tengo que hacerlo así he pasado toda mi
vida aquí
me duele pero al mismo tiempo necesito
necesito volver a ver mi casa por un
tiempo antes de que sea demolida
[Música]
está en marcha un procedimiento de
expropiación la casa de su familia será
destruida y ser indemnizado
el pensionado tm que está su mano le
permite encontrar un nuevo hogar en ten
ha pensado en dejar té
no nunca
este es mi país aquí es donde nací a
donde
mis raíces están intento
mis hábitos están aquí no me quiero ir
por eso tenemos que ayudar a la gente
como yo a quedarse
como ser una docena de familias tendrán
que llorar la pérdida de su hogar
jean-pierre vassallo ha sido alcalde de
la comuna durante más de 20 años la
semana pasada tuvo que decirle otra
víctima que no podrá volver a su casa
no sabes lo triste que fue cuando
tuvimos que ni siquiera me atreví a
hacerlo cuando tuvimos que decirles
vamos a destruir tu casa
es un golpe mortal para una familia y
todavía me siento mal por ello
un año después de la tormenta 55
familias siguen sin poder volver a casa
están esperando el refuerzo de los
bancos algunos ya han optado por el
exilio
estamos aquí para reconstruir para que
la gente se recupere tenemos que superar
esto por encima de todo la gente debería
volver al pueblo volver esa es la
palabra clave que la gente vuelva porque
lo dice
porque me gustaría el alcalde
desde octubre del año pasado seguido
muchas familias definitivamente para
vivir abajo
lo entristece bueno eso es triste hay un
pueblo que me perdonen la expresión está
muerto
[Música]
italia se dio el pueblo de tent a
francia tras la segunda guerra mundial
la ciudad siempre ha tenido una
población de unos dos mil habitantes
desde la tormenta un cuarto de ellos han
abandonado el municipio y el éxodo
podría continuar se acaba de trazar una
nueva ruta que delimita la zona de
peligro cerrada a las viviendas
básicamente afectará a otras cinco o
seis casas y en total
en definitiva es mucho más en total si
se suman los 11 que han desaparecido y
los 56 que desaparecerán empieza a pesar
que
en un pueblo la importancia de una casa
es una familia
los niños que van a la escuela el
negocio que funciona es todo el
equilibrio del pueblo
pero también el de las estructuras que
hay los médicos la farmacia el mercado
es este equilibrio perfecto el que
debemos conseguir preservar
para mantener este equilibrio los
servicios públicos han tenido que
adaptarse a gran velocidad
marilyn que tiene en la mano tengo un
poco de medicina la oficina de correos
los entrega desde este verano la
farmacia cerró el 30 de junio los
medicamentos se piden en el mismo día
hasta las 11 30 horas la oficina de
correos los recoge en el pueblo cercano
de 'break' y los entrega entre las 13 y
las 15 horas a los clientes hola cómo
estás
pequeña entrega de medicamentos
[Música]
voy a necesitar una firma como
como le hubiera ido sin este servicio
seguro que nos habría dado mucha
vergüenza incluso estábamos considerando
oírnos nos apoyamos mutuamente pero los
dos estamos enfermos y sin coche
ha notado que hay menos gente en el
valle desde la tormenta
sí por supuesto en primer lugar en el
contexto de mi actividad profesional hay
buzones a los que ya no se les entrega
el core o casas que están cerradas y
también me doy cuenta personalmente soy
madre de un niño de nueve años sé que en
la escuela faltan unos cincuenta niños
[Música]
a parte de un ferrocarril envejecido la
actividad y la economía del pueblo
dependen de dos vías de acceso una hacia
la vecina italia la otra hacia la costa
francesa desde la tormenta la primera
está intransitable la segunda aún está
en construcción
lo que ha cambiado es que se prolonga
nuestro tiempo en la carretera perdemos
tiempo en el coche que antes no
perdíamos y esto ha mejorado
considerablemente hoy todo estaba
asfaltado y todo es bueno pero al
principio pasábamos por una pista
todos los días me perturba mirar la roya
o las partes de la carretera que han
sido arrasadas todos los días pienso en
lo que pasó y deploró todo el año es una
herida que no se ha cerrado
nadie es una enfermera privada ella
también tuvo que abandonar su casa cuyos
cimientos quedaron al descubierto por
las aguas
en las semanas siguientes a la
catástrofe a pesar del trauma y el
cansancio continúo con sus rondas hoy le
gustaría tomarse un respiro pero es
imposible contratar
antes de la tormenta éramos tres
enfermeras solo quedamos dos nuestra
tercera compañera tenía un plan de vida
para irse a trabajar a la costa pero el
problema era que no podía ser sustituido
porque no había suficientes pacientes
presencialmente trabajamos mucho no
tenemos muchos menos clientes le pesa en
su vida diaria es una carga para el día
a día porque es largo llevamos un año un
año trabajando así
[Música]
conmovido por todo el apoyo recibido
armand decidió conservar su rebaño y su
granja
se espera conocer su indemnización
admite que está dispuesto a hacer
cualquier cosa para quedarse en su
pueblo natal incluso si eso significa
volver a instalarse en su casa para
protestar el alcalde sigue luchando por
devolver la vida a su aldea y espera
encontrar pronto nuevos terrenos
edificables en el municipio
en el valle de las maravillas la
tormenta alex ha dejado profundas
heridas a su paso que solo el tiempo
parece curar
[Música]
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a todo recuerda que si
quieres ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto